[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el 2022
comienza con una nueva escalada de
tensión en torno a los deseos de ucrania
de ingresar a la otan la alianza de
defensa atlántica que es liderada por
eeuu a la que pertenece una buena parte
de los países europeos y que rusia ve
como una amenaza a su seguridad y una
clara intromisión en su zona de
influencia dado que ucrania no es solo
una ex república soviética sino que
también es un país étnicamente eslavo
con el que rusia comparte siglos de
historia en común y donde se puede decir
que nació el pueblo ruso siglos atrás en
la rush de kiev la amenaza de una
invasión de rusia a la región del
donbass en el este de ucrania es la gran
preocupación de la comunidad
internacional esto recuerda ya a lo
sucedido en las regiones de abjasia y de
osetia del sur en georgia y también la
reciente anexión de la península de
crimea a rusia que no ha sido reconocida
por la comunidad internacional la
situación provoca y un intercambio de
argumentos y señalamientos entre rusia
ucrania estados unidos la otan y la
unión europea esta es la perspectiva
rusa todo radica en una amenaza
escuchemos
no estamos amenazando a nadie pero
escuchamos amenazas dirigidas a nosotros
no podemos aceptar algunas demandas
relacionadas con operaciones militares
en nuestro propio territorio
por supuesto también la casa blanca ha
respondido y fue muy clara la respuesta
al dejar el balón en la mano de los
rusos según washington todo depende de
cómo van a reaccionar desde el kremlin
hay dos caminos hay un camino
diplomático a seguir ciertamente
esperamos que tomen este camino existe
el otro camino depende de los rusos
determinar qué camino van a tomar y las
consecuencias serán graves si no toman
el camino diplomático por supuesto que
de otros actores implicados que ya vamos
a analizar más adelante en el programa
el papel de ucrania por supuesto es el
territorio donde están ocurriendo todas
estas escaladas de tensión hasta donde
han llegado en su frontera común con
rusia algunos
en grupos de soldados del ejército ruso
también está la otan y la unión europea
que muchos han criticado por su falta de
firmeza y de presencia en esta crisis y
por supuestamente estar cediendo terreno
a moscú y washington en esas
conversaciones en donde bruselas y sobre
todo kiev deberían tener más
participación la nueva escalada de
tensión en ucrania es nuestro tema de
debate en france 24 y para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a ruth febrero
ferrero perdón ella es docente de
ciencia política y estudios europeos en
la universidad complutense de madrid en
españa ella también es investigadora
adscrita del instituto de estudios
internacionales se une a esta
conversación precisamente desde madrid
la capital española y también está con
nosotros
vladimir rubinsky él es profesor de
ciencia política y relaciones
internacionales de la universidad icesi
en la ciudad de cali en el sur de
colombia se está conectando a esta
conversación precisamente desde esta
ciudad colombiana ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas los pueden hacer a través
de nuestras redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram y en
twitter estamos como france24
y arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo la etiqueta para
que dejen todos los comentarios y las
preguntas numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas comienzo de inmediato el
debate en la ciudad de madrid con ruth
ferrero y bueno ruth tenemos una nueva
escalada una nueva un nuevo intercambio
de comentarios y de acusaciones entre
washington moscú también algunos pasan
por bruselas y por kiev pero hay una
verdadera amenaza real de una invasión
por parte de rusia al este de ucrania
como lo ve usted
bueno yo no creo que exista realmente
una amenaza real de conquistar
territorio como tal de hecho tenemos que
recordar que sigue un conflicto abierto
en las regiones del donbass en la cual
hay un apoyo logístico y del ejército
ruso a las unidades pro rusas ya los
independentistas rusos en la región por
lo tanto estamos ya en un conflicto
abierto
y además a rusia el objetivo del
objetivo que tiene es básicamente
en tener desestabilizado a ucrania para
con el fin de evitar que se una a la
alianza atlántica entonces cualquier
ocupación o cualquier anexión como lo
que sucedió en crimea no ayudaría
digamos a conseguir los objetivos que
tiene que tenemos con la cadera y
vladimir rubís que en la ciudad de cali
en el sur de colombia le hago la misma
pregunta estamos ante una nueva escalada
de tensión nuevamente washington y moscú
o enfrentándose a través de esos canales
diplomáticos pero hay una verdadera
amenaza de una posible invasión por
parte de a rúa ucrania
bueno yo creo que si existe una amenaza
y esto es el mensaje que quiere mandar
la rusia de vladimir putin en el mismo
tiempo coincide el control de que hay un
conflicto que nunca ha parado que un
conflicto que costaba más de
13.400 vidas y donde hay presencia por
lo menos de algunos consejeros de parte
de rusia
sin embargo una guerra abierta por parte
de rusia una invasión abierta con las
tropas identificados como las tropas
rusas va a costar a rusia muchísimo más
tanto en cuanto a los costos reales para
hacer una guerra además hay un invierno
duro ahí esta no es la mejor época para
un combate pero también claramente va a
llegar a es la rusia aún más de la arena
internacional
ruth en la ciudad de madrid' usted
mencionaba que el trasfondo una de las
razones de esta escalada de tensión es
ese posible ingreso de ucrania a la
alianza de la otan que otros argumentos
puede estar utilizando el kremlin para
lanzar estas amenazas para desplegar
estos soldados allí en la frontera común
con ucrania y para generar esta tensión
incluso hasta con washington al otro
lado del atlántico más allá de esa
discrepancia que hay en torno a la
expansión que ha tenido la otan en los
países del este desde la caída de la
unión soviética
bueno la cuestión es que putin necesita
necesita mantener la tensión fuera para
mantener su popularidad dentro del país
eso es un primer punto que creo que
tenemos que tener en consideración
en segundo lugar
desde mi punto de vista creo que se
piensa efectivamente hay un despliegue
de tropas rusas en la frontera ucraniana
que se ha concentrado los últimos en los
últimos meses especialmente en los meses
de invierno
con el frío invierno y ese duro invierno
ucraniano
pero también creo que ha habido una
cierta
apuesta por parte de las posiciones
euroatlánticas para tensionar y dibujar
un escenario de amenaza que no es una
amenaza real a la anexión de la región
del donbass sino que es una estrategia
negociadora de putin el tensionar estas
este diálogo estas negociaciones que
hemos visto la semana pasada en
/ en ginebra / entre eeuu y rusia
lo que hace es un escenario
multilateral de negociación pues poner
encima de la mesa esas cartas no también
a nivel discursivo hemos escuchado como
como putin ha amenazado con
desplazar digamos misiles o fuerzas o
fuerzas en cuba y en y en venezuela
entonces bueno pues se trata se trataría
un poco de poner encima de la mesa las
cartas que cada uno tiene
e intentar negociar a la más grande no
si está una suerte de órdago a la grande
por su parte eeuu también está jugando
sus propias cartas y también tiene se
está jugando digamos la viabilidad y el
sentido del sentido de la existencia de
la propia de la propia otan si no hay
una amenaza real la otan quizás no
tendría tanto sentido y las inversiones
en materia de defensa por parte de los
socios de la otan pues tampoco lo
tendría claro
vladimir en route menciona esa necesidad
del presidente vladimir putin de mejorar
su popularidad distensionar un poco
algunos temas internos sobre todo con
estos temas de pandemia y la crisis
económica que está enfrentando el país a
raíz de unas sanciones económicas y
también porque la anexión de la
península de crimea al territorio ruso
fue bastante productiva digamos para el
presidente putin en términos de
popularidad ni para ganar otra vez en
favorabilidad de diferentes sectores de
la sociedad rusa está el presidente
putin jugándose esta misma carta con el
donbass y con esta nueva escalada de
tensión y cómo es la situación de putin
al interior de la federación
es una muy buena pregunta porque yo creo
que en este caso particular en el caso
de ucrania no se trata de un intento de
ganar popularidad a pesar que todo
indica que la popularidad de vladimir
putin ha bajado indus ya los rusos están
cansados de ver la cara de putt en todo
el tiempo y hay dificultades económicas
aunque hay que decir algo que yo creo
que es muy importante en este contexto
que los rusos siguen viviendo bastante
bien yo creo que bajo el régimen de
putin una de las ventajas es que los
rusos nunca han vivido tan bien como
viven en este momento a pesar de todas
las dificultades la guerra y la guerra
en rusia no es popular entonces yo creo
que es un movimiento completamente
diferente en comparación con 2014 cuando
realmente la anexión de crimea ayudó a
putin a aumentar tremendamente la
popularidad ahora la idea de la guerra
es completamente impopular y si rusia
hace una guerra yo creo que esto no
necesariamente va a apoyar a vladimir
putin
yo creo que se trata de una estrategia
completamente diferente es una
estrategia que busca forzar a los eeuu
negociar los rasgos de un nuevo orden
internacional
negociar qué tipo de rasgos en ese orden
internacional y qué es lo que estaría
entonces en esa mesa de negociación
entre estas dos partes ampliando un poco
más lo que usted dice
yo creo que vladimir putin durante el
año pasado estaba esperando que el tema
de las relaciones entre eeuu y rusia
iba a ser una de las probabilidades de
la gente de jobvite en el nuevo
presidente de los eeuu y esto no ocurrió
para eeuu y hubo otras prioridades en
cuanto al arian internacional obviamente
lo más importante sigue siendo yo creo a
pesar de todo para eeuu son las
relaciones con china y vladimir putin se
sentó excluido y utilizó algo que él
estaba utilizando antes una amenaza
mover las tropas que ocurrió por ejemplo
en siria cuando a barack obama le tocaba
sentarse y negociar computen y él lo
hizo de nuevo yo creo que vladimir putin
lo que quiere es realmente ser parte
activa de estos negociaciones acerca
cuál va a ser el nuevo orden
internacional y quiere demandar el papel
de una gran potencia demandará un
protagonismo a nivel internacional ruth
tal vez puede ser una de las razones que
están llevando al presidente putin a
este tipo de acciones en lo que dice y
sobre todo que el presidente putin va a
estar gobernando la federación de rusia
hasta el 2034 tiene que mostrarse como
un líder firme y de importancia a nivel
internacional esto estaría siendo
aprovechado por el kremlin
aprovechando esa
rara política exterior que tiene eeuu
que no ha logrado afianzarse con la
llegada del presidente by the end y
también esas deficiencias que tiene la
política exterior de la unión europea a
la hora de tomar decisiones tomar
posiciones en este tipo de conflictos
como lo ve usted si ya estoy muy de
acuerdo con mi colega y creo que
lo que quiere rusia es jugar un papel
fundamental quiere volver a hacer gran
potencia es una de las de las bajas con
las que pone encima de la mesa putin es
lo que ha intentado transmitir a lo
largo de estos años a la población que
rusia cuenta que rusia no es la rusia de
yeltsin sino que rusia cuenta y que
cuenta en la arena internacional y lo
que nos estamos encontrando es que los
últimos tiempos es ese papel que jugaba
a rusia como rival digamos de las
potencias occidentales no es tan lógico
está jugando ahora mismo china y rusia
no quiere que eso suceda o no quiere
quedarse al margen de las
decisiones que se puedan adoptar en esta
suerte de corte y de enfrentamiento que
tienen en la actualidad estados unidos y
china por lo tanto si quiere poner en el
tablero mundial la alabanza y la fuerza
digamos para
reivindicarse como como gran potencia en
hoy de y por eso también deja fuera al
igual que por cierto eeuu deja fuera la
unión europea y pasando al tema de la
unión europea lo que nos estamos
encontrando es que efectivamente y la
autonomía estratégica
está llegando tarde
en este momento puesto que no tenemos la
capacidad o no se tiene la capacidad
desde desde la unión europea para poner
encima de la mesa argumentos y para
poder negociar al unísono entre todos
los estados entre todos los estados y
tener una posición común en relación con
esta con esta cuestión de hecho los
mismos viajes del alto representante
básicamente tenían como objetivo pues
poner a la unión europea en el en el
mapa y vemos también cómo el grupo de
normandía se ha visto desintegrado grupo
normal ya que porque negoció en el caso
en el caso de ucrania ha quedado
absolutamente fuera de juego y lo que lo
que quiere precisamente en la unión
europea y sobre todo esta comisión
geopolítica que pretendía sergio
política que se ha visto lastrada por
por la pandemia es efectivamente darle
una voz fuerte en el mundo a la unión
europea algo que en esta ocasión no está
consiguiendo en otras quizás sí que
podamos ver rute quiero continuar con
usted para preguntarle para ampliar el
tema de la unión europea usted menciona
falta de capacidad a qué se refiere
exactamente con esa falta de capacidad
tiene poco margen de negociación la
unión europea para este tipo de crisis
su escenario tiene poco que ofrecer
como eeuu o rusia si pueden entrar a
negociar o simplemente aquí queda claro
el peso de la unión europea a nivel
internacional frente a washington y
moscú que se han sentado a hablar
dejando de lado a bruselas hacia kiev
bueno lo que sucede es que no tenemos
una verdadera política exterior europea
es decir no hablamos todos los países
con la misma voz y con las mismas
posiciones
pensemos justamente en el día d en el
día de hoy se ha reunido el presidente
de sánchez con el preclaro el canciller
scholz y las posiciones geopolíticas de
los dos países son muy diferentes en la
dependencia del gas que tiene que tiene
alemania con la apertura del norte
stream y
como sea como sea
articulado el
discurso alemán en relación con rusia
manteniendo digamos de manera aislada el
acceso a la energía con
desvinculándolo de las crisis
geopolíticas que estamos viendo en la
frontera en la frontera oriental esto es
algo que en alemania está generando
mucho debate dentro incluso del propio
partido socialista alemán y por supuesto
con los socios de coalición por otro
lado en europa no hemos conseguido
además de no tener esa política exterior
unitaria digamos hablar con esa única
voz y tener una posición realmente única
en relación con con la vecindad en este
caso con con moscú y tampoco tenemos una
alternativa de política energética
diferente que nos haga ser menos
dependientes de el gas del gas ruso
especialmente en europa en europa
central y del este y eso hacer que todos
los argumentos pues queden un poco
tamizados digamos y la asertividad de la
política exterior que en este caso
podría jugar un papel
importante en este entre entre esa entre
esas negociaciones de eeuu y rusia y
queda queda muy desdibujada y déjenme a
solamente apuntar una última cosa
by den también está interesado en que la
negociación sea entre deseados es decir
en revivir digamos ese espacio ese es el
contexto de guerra fría en el cual dos
superpotencias negocia sobre la
arquitectura de seguridad europea esa y
yo lo muchas veces lo cuento así es como
es ese muñequito del del ordenador que
salta y que salta queriendo llamar la
atención es decir no no es que no quiero
que me hagan ustedes la arquitectura de
seguridad que yo quiero formar parte de
este quiero además saber y quiero
aportar sobre cómo quiero yo construir
mi propia seguridad además de los
intereses energéticos que también tiene
eeuu que está deseoso de vender petróleo
gas y suministros energéticos a la unión
europea y por eso ha bloqueado en cierta
manera la puesta en marcha del del
gasoducto nord stream que llevaría gas
ruso desde el golfo de finlandia hasta
las costas alemanas no empezaba a
funcionar y ya lo están cerrando en su
funcionamiento prácticamente pues no ha
sido puesto en marcha a lo largo de este
invierno
vladimir aquí un punto importante ya
analizamos moscú ya analizamos un poco
la posición de washington y de la unión
europea y nos queda el otro actor que es
ucrania que es el territorio que está en
la mitad de toda esta disputa de egos de
ganas de posicionamiento internacional
pero quién va a defender a ucrania en
caso de una invasión qué importancia
tiene ucrania además de ser punto de
tránsito de muchos de los gasoductos
rusos hacia el centro de europa
porque ucrania
excelente pregunta porque ucrania yo
creo que para rusia no hay otro país de
las ex repúblicas de la unión soviética
que tiene tanta importancia y simbólica
porque el conflicto entre rusia y
ucrania
prácticamente es un conflicto entre este
eje oeste recordamos que los cambios que
ocurrieron en ucrania terminando el año
2013 comenzando 2014 precisamente era un
conflicto que se inició porque el
presidente en ese entonces yanukóvich
decidió no continuar el proceso de
acercamiento con la unión europea y esto
generó prácticamente su huida la caída
del régimen y claramente dejó vladimir
putin completamente
desacuerdo en desacuerdo con esta
situación
como usted ya mencionó al inicio del
programa a rusia que ucrania comparten
los mitos convencionales compartan las
respuestas a las preguntas de dónde
provienen sus naciones
esto que hace la posición de ucrania tan
particular en este contexto de todos
estos cambios geopolíticos quién va a
defender a ucrania en primer lugar va a
defender ellos mismos yo creo que el
ejército ucraniano ahora es mucho más
preparado mucho más entrenado además
está en una guerra real durante tantos
años no es la ucrania de 2014 que
realmente no pudo hacer ninguna
resistencia a rusia y rusia logró anexar
crémer yo creo que la situación va a ser
completamente diferente ahora y esto
también debe ser una de las razones por
qué rusia no creo que va a tomar la
decisión de atacar o ucrania
abiertamente ruth y teniendo en cuenta
este escenario y este libreto que hemos
visto también en países de algo similar
como lo que sucedió en georgia también
hace algunos años lo mencionaba yo con
osetia del sur y abjasia
también un poco la mano que ha puesto
moscú sobre belarús con el tema de los
migrantes durante el verano que trataban
de entrar a la unión europea a través de
la frontera con polonia y lituania que
otro país podría estar bajo amenaza de
verse en este mismo escenario
simplemente por tratar de
apostarle algo en su política digamos
entrar a la unión europea o entrar a la
alianza de la otan que puede ser una
decisión autónoma de cada uno de los
estados pero que a rusia puede que no le
parezca o que haya discrepancias
entonces con bruselas hoy estoy acuerdo
con mi colega en que en que ucrania
simbólicamente representa representa
mucho para rusia en su narrativa de
construcción de la nación rusa y de las
quizás de las repúblicas exsoviéticas de
los rusos de la vela rusia bielorrusia y
belarús
gracias a ucrania y moldavia son las que
más arraigo digamos algo une no la pata
que más cercana está europa y está ahí
donde también rusia no quiere dejar de
tener influencia y por ahí esa
importancia ha dicho usted que
rusia tuvo que ver con los
desplazamientos de emigrantes no a la
frontera con lituania y con polonia yo
eso no lo tengo confirmado
que rus haya tenido algo que ver creo ke
lukashenka y se sobra solo para poder
poner en marcha esa esa cuestión en todo
caso en relación con el conflicto
ucraniano pensemos que también podemos
analizarlo desde un punto de vista que
no sea estrictamente del punto de vista
occidental y también lo que no se dice
demasiado en los medios es que lo que
está pidiendo rusia es que haya un
cumplimiento de los acuerdos de mick en
el caso de ucrania y es algo que ha
puesto encima de la mesa en las últimas
en las últimas negociaciones por lo
tanto también había que prestar atención
precisamente a esos acuerdos que se así
que se hicieron
en el marco del cuarteto de normandía
y khe en el año 2015 y el año 2016 y que
están sin cumplir y están sin cumplir en
parte porque hay una vulneración de esos
acuerdos por parte de las tropas
ucranianas eso también creo que que es
importante decirlo y aparte de eso estoy
de acuerdo también con vladimir que
ucrania está muy profesionalizado al
ejército nuestro mismo que se
encontraron en el comienzo de la crisis
y que además y al igual que rusia está
armando a los a los rebeldes del donbass
también las tropas ucranianas están
siendo ayudadas en varios ámbitos por
parte de las potencias occidentales no
podemos olvidar que que está habiendo
ese apoyo implícito y explícito también
sobre el terreno por lo tanto yo creo
que en este en este tipo de conflictos
es importante poner encima de la mesa
cuáles son las distintas posiciones de
una manera lo más objetiva posible y por
lo tanto reivindicar decir bueno se
quieren o no cumplir los acuerdos de
mails son válidos o no son válidos
porque vuelvo a me retrotraigo al pasado
usted ha comentado también la guerra en
georgia pero la guerra georgia también
tuvo un origen que tiene que ver con la
cumbre de budapest del año 2008 en el
que se amenazó con el despliegue de
misiles
scud antimisiles en la república checa
en polonia la respuesta inmediata de
moscú fue la cuestión de georgia pero
cuidado porque saakashvili también tuvo
algo que hacer ahí para que bojan una
reacción por parte de rusia por lo tanto
yo creo que es importante que el relato
esté completo por todas las partes para
evitar sesgos de cualquier tipo desde
cualquiera claro me gustaría añadir que
muchos de los argumentos de moscú ha
sido que precisamente las violaciones de
estos acuerdos y las faltas y los
cumplimientos es lo que ha llevado a
muchas de estas respuestas y ellos se
remontan incluso a acuerdos de la época
de la década del 90 donde prometía la
otan no extenderse al este y pues los
tres estados bálticos entraron a formar
parte de la alianza quedando con
frontera directamente con rusia y son
reclamos que hace moscú también a
occidente occidente no ha dado ningún
tipo de respuesta
exacto
añadir una cosa simplemente eso es así
pero también es así que los estados de
la de la órbita sobre los antiguos
estados soviéticos bielorrusia ucrania
moldavia los tocas los del cáucaso todos
ellos además son estados soberanos en la
actualidad y rusia no puede decidir por
ello que esto es algo que también se
olvida nos olvidamos muchas veces de
decir es decir efectivamente hay unos
acuerdos pero rusia tampoco puede
opinar y tomar decisiones exacto por
parte de esos estados que eso me lleva a
la pregunta que le quería hacer a
vladimir y es entonces qué
decisiones puede tomar ucrania que
posiciona abandonar su idea de ingresar
a la unión europea tratar de tener una
posición un poco más neutral llevando
por una cordialidad la relación con
moscú bruselas kiev qué opciones puede
tener este país para evitar un conflicto
para evitar más tensiones y volver un
poco a la normalidad porque recordemos
la profunda crisis económica y la
cantidad de ucranianos que han dejado el
país en los últimos años precisamente
porque es se ha presentado todo este
tipo de dificultades políticas
económicas y
con la guerra en el este
lamentablemente creo que ucrania no
tiene muchas opciones
ucrania lamentablemente o sea en primer
lugar es un país independiente
nadie puede negar la independencia de
ucrania na nadie puede decir que ucrania
no es un país independiente es un país
con su propio store es un país que ha
logrado la soberanía y estoy totalmente
de acuerdo con duda que rusia no puede
decir a ucrania que puede y que no puede
hacer ucrania si no estamos en el siglo
19 no estamos en la época de los
imperios aunque a veces el discurso ruso
nos indica que en esta idea del imperio
sigue siendo muy viva si ahora yo creo
que hay puntos a favor de ucrania y
puntos contra cuáles son los puntos a
favor yo creo yo creo que ucrania sobre
todo ha logrado construir una identidad
nacional y han pasado muchos años donde
esta identidad fue discutida donde esta
identidad fue realmente como con mucha
ambigüedad incluso dentro de la misma
ucrania ahora es una nación es una
nación que tiene la idea y que tiene
realmente un sentido de lealtad a la
nación este es un factor a favor cuál es
el factor contra claramente el estado de
la economía ucraniana hay mucha
corrupción hay unos escándalos a
expresidente de ucrania que va a la
cárcel y yo creo que hay un poder de la
soledad que está ya no cráneo que
realmente todavía tiene una influencia
fuerte sobre la toma de decisiones en
ucrania entonces yo creo que
lamentablemente no hay muchas acciones
pero el deseo personalmente mucha suerte
a ucrania quiero que ellos deben
encontrar una salir de esta situación
tan bilis ruth vladimir entramos a la
recta final del programa antes de entrar
a las conclusiones quiero hablar un poco
de lo que puede suceder en la región de
américa latina y en nuestro continente a
raíz de comentarios que han hecho desde
el kremlin de la posibilidad de
desplegar militares en venezuela y en
cuba
si empieza esto a escalar sea otros
niveles entre eeuu y rusia ustedes
verían posible este escenario desplegar
otra vez
esta atención con cuba y con venezuela y
militares en estos países
latinoamericanos ruth que piensa usted
bueno antes de responder quería
solamente anotar que ucrania nunca de
momento ha tenido ninguna oferta para
entrar en la unión europea el adhesiones
para entrar en la otan o en la unión
europea hay una perspectiva europea pero
no tiene que ver con la agresión a la
unión europea en cuanto al potencial
despliegue de tropas o de misiles en lo
que américa latina en venezuela en cuba
bueno ya dijo creo que recordar que hace
unos días en que estábamos en un
contexto bueno putin o algún ministro
del gobierno de por terrorismo ruso
estábamos en un contexto de crisis de
los misiles no es verdad que no
solamente desde el lado ruso que se ha
hablado de un momento de distensión de
éter grande
en el signo también desde el lado
norteamericano y yo creo que esta nueva
brava está de putin tiene mucho que ver
con que eeuu sienta efectivamente lo que
lo que putin considera que está
sintiendo el pueblo ruso al intentar
adherir a ucrania por ejemplo a la
organización del atlántico norte no
decir te voy a que voy a pagar con la
misma moneda yo también tengo capacidad
de desplegar tropas y misiles en tu
patrio en tu patio trasero en tus
fronteras y seguro que eso no te va a
gustar no ir con eso pensamos de nuevo
la cuerda y de nuevo estamos en ese
escenario negociador que comentábamos
antes no la cuestión es ver cómo también
responden digamos los los estados
latinoamericanos en relación con esto y
que puede llegar a pensar eeuu cómo
puede llegar a responder vaivén que por
de momento todavía no ha hecho ninguna
ninguna maniobra digamos de respuesta
ante ante está ante esta propuesta qué
y
algo que decir sobre este tema ya para
el cierre antes de las conclusiones
sí yo creo que en el caso ruso el
gobieron da vladimir putin está
cometiendo el mismo error que está
cometiendo
cuando está hablando que no permitir a
ucrania entrar a otan tanto cuba como
venezuela son los países soberanos
moscú no puede hablar
por cuba no puede hablar por venezuela
yo creo el xperia creo que la
experiencia de la crisis de los mísiles
es una experiencia muy delicada para los
cubanos recordamos que existe el castro
estaba muy de desacuerdo cómo terminó
esta crisis él se sentía traicionado por
rusia y de hecho yo creo que los cubanos
y la rusia de ahora nunca han logrado
construir el mismo ingrediente confianza
que existía antes si en el caso de
venezuela la constitución venezolana no
permite poner las tropas extranjeros en
el terreno de mis manos y posiblemente
maduro puede inventar algo pero yo creo
que este es muy lejos de hacer de verdad
a está precisamente de una reciprocidad
simbólica que sirve para el público ruso
pero no es algo que vamos a ver pronto
aquí me queda un minuto y medio para el
cierre del programa root sus
conclusiones de lo que puede suceder
siempre lo digo no tenemos la bola de
cristal para saber el futuro pero que en
qué puede terminar todo esto
bueno de momento parece que acaba en
tablas las negociaciones en ginebra cada
año las tenemos a primeros de año entre
eeuu y rusia no avanzamos desde el punto
de vista de la unión europea no tenemos
una estrategia hacia rusia común
desde hace mucho tiempo tenemos
caducados los acuerdos bilaterales con
rusia y yo creo que en tanto en cuanto
en la unión europea no consiga articular
una posición común en relación a qué
tipo de relación quieren mantener con
rusia va a seguir escorada en las
negociaciones que tienen que que tienen
como objetivo digamos esa construcción
de la arquitectura de seguridad y eso yo
creo que es clave para el caso para el
caso de la neurona vladimir para el
cierre su conclusión
yo creo que lo más importante de la
crisis actual es una lección que a pesar
de que hay otros temas de prioridad hay
pandemia obviamente que está ocupando la
atención de los políticos no podemos
olvidar sobre los conflictos como en el
centro de europa prácticamente que son
ucrania debemos no tardar en encontrar
una solución porque si nos tardamos y
ignoramos realmente vamos a enfrentar la
situación como agua yo creo que es la
elección más importante pues a ruth
ferrero en la ciudad de madrid ya
vladimir rubinsky en la ciudad de cali
en colombia les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros haber hecho este
análisis y por haber aclarado puntos
importantes sobre esta situación que se
está viviendo en ucrania ustedes pueden
seguir dejando todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]